long before Rosa Parks refused to move
to the back of the bus homer plessy
boarded a train car in New Orleans to
protest Jim Crow segregation laws Plessy
was arrested and convicted in Louisiana
but his test case for segregated public
transportation reached the Supreme Court
in 1896 this is Kim from Kahn Academy
and today we're learning more about the
landmark case Plessy vs. Ferguson which
asked whether separate but equal
accommodations for black and white
Americans violated the Fourteenth
Amendment of the Constitution to learn
more about this case I spoke with two
experts Jamaal green is the dwight
professor of law at Columbia Law School
Earl Maltz is a distinguished professor
of law at Rutgers law school so
professor green could you kind of set
the stage for us in this time period
after the Civil War what was the legal
and social status of former slaves well
of course the Civil War ended in 1865
and it was fought in large part over the
institution of chattel slavery so
slavery of generally speaking a black or
african-american slaves and right at the
end of the Civil War the Thirteenth
Amendment was passed and the Thirteenth
Amendment basically said that there
shouldn't be any slavery or involuntary
servitude in the United States so the
institution of slavery itself had ended
but the passage of the 13th amendment
did not mean that former slaves had
equal rights a number of the former
states of the Confederacy the generally
speaking southern states passed a number
of racially discriminatory laws
immediately after the end of slavery
that prevented black Americans from
participating in civil society on equal
terms with whites for example laws
restricting the ability of blacks to
enter into and enforce contracts
restricting the ability of blacks to own
property to sit on juries to vote to
testify in court and so forth so there
were a number of openly discriminatory
laws there are also laws that required
blacks to be employed on pain of having
their Lee
forced so ways of essentially
reinstituting the institution of slavery
and these were known as the Black Codes
those are known as the Black Codes
exactly in the Reconstruction period
between the say the late 1860's and the
mid 1870s there was a concerted effort
by the federal government to improve the
social status and political rights of
African Americans in 1876 there's part
of the settlement of the presidential
election of 1876 the federal government
drew back some but most of the read of
the so-called Redeemer movement really
took off in the 1890s
I think 1891 is when the last real
effort is made by the federal government
to have a serious Voting Rights Act and
after that the south is pretty much
under control of the people who
sympathized with ex-confederates in both
northern and southern states there was
widespread racial segregation so there
were laws that were basically codifying
long existing social practices of
segregated housing segregated schools
and segregated public conveyances like
steamships and rail cars but much of
that changed in the years immediately
following the Civil War Congress passed
a number of federal laws that banned
racial discrimination particularly in
contracting and in housing quite
significantly in addition to the actual
federal laws that Congress passed the
country passed and ratified the 14th
amendment so I think one thing that is
very hard for me to understand and that
I see I've seen students struggle with
is you have the passage of the 14th
amendment and the 15th amendment in the
1868 1870 and these are supposed to
guarantee equal protection and
citizenship and voting rights for
African Americans specifically men in
the 15th amendment and then then you
have Jim Crow so how did we get
this this moment after the Civil War
where things really seem like they're
looking up in terms of african-american
citizenship to the system of Jim Crow
that's going to persist into the 1960s
and 70s the civil war did not end racism
it simply ended slavery and so we're
still living in a racial a racist
society in which residential and school
segregation remained both in southern
states and in northern states
notwithstanding the the Civil Rights
amendments and in southern states
reconstruction with the process of
trying to bring former slaves fully into
civil society was enforced by the
presence of federal troops in southern
states on the theory the very well
founded theory that states that had just
gone to war in order to perpetuate the
institution of slavery we're not going
to willingly adopt equal rights for the
former slaves that they had just been
been holding in bondage and so there was
a federal military occupation of a
number of former Confederate States for
a good decade plus after the Civil War
really ending in 1877 and at that point
again through the Redeemer movement
people who were the white power
structure most of which had had what had
sympathized with the secessionist
movement the white power structure and
its successors took power back in the
beginning the mid 1870s from the in the
southern states and as part of their
campaign they imposed the Jim Crow
system slavery was not just about labor
it was really a system of racial
hierarchy and many in the United States
remained committed to that system even
after bondage itself ended and if you
don't have the political will within the
northern states to enforce the
Reconstruction Amendments you had really
a retrenchment of deep racial inequality
within the southern states but but not
just within the son
States but also within a number of
northern states as well so let's kind of
dial into the case Plessy versus
Ferguson who was Homer Plessy and why
did he take issue with segregation well
the law that was that issue required
what wasn't very separate and equal
separate but equal accommodation of
African Americans and whites in on on
public transportation Homer Plessy
objected to it because a the facilities
weren't really equal and he objected to
it because he was and in part because he
was classified as black but also in
general because he thought that that was
demeaning obviously a majority of
members of the Supreme Court believed
that the southern stage should be should
have at least some leeway in to
establish their this system of racial
segregation and so Plessy was in league
with the rail the railroad and with the
civil rights organization that recruited
him to set up a case so he agreed with
the railroad to board the white area of
the of the railway car on a car going
from New Orleans to a town called
Covington and it was agreed that the
railway would ask him to leave he would
refuse and then he would be arrested and
once he was arrested that wouldn't
enable him to challenge the law under
which he was arrested under the
Constitution the railroads didn't like
this law they didn't like this law
because they didn't want to be subject
to up to fines or liability for for not
properly maintaining separate cars it
was really up to the conductor's to make
sure that separate cars were maintained
and that the conductors themselves could
be fined by the state for not doing so
and it could also be fined by passengers
for mistakenly putting someone in the
wrong car
so the railroads didn't really want to
be bothered with this kind of law and so
this particular railroad Eastern Railway
was willing to agree to set up a
situation to challenge the law so Homer
Plessy he gets on this train and he
challenges the statute I believe he he
sat in a whites-only car and announced
that he was African American and then he
was arrested so what happened next he's
arrested and then he is eventually
charged with a crime with a violation of
the statute and he is the and there's a
fine associated with violating the state
law and his lawyers bring a claim that
the the law violates the Federal
Constitution so it in Ischl ii it goes
through the state courts of louisiana
and then eventually they rule against
Homer Plessy and in favor of the law and
then his lawyers appeal the case to the
to the US Supreme Court so how did the
court rule in the years leading up to
the case the lawyers for Homer Plessy
were quite concerned about the
composition of the court because they
weren't sure if they could count five
votes in favor of black civil rights
because none of the justices on the
court were considered to be particularly
friends of black Americans in the civil
rights cases in 1860 in 1883 excuse me
the court had already held that Congress
lacked authority to prohibit segregation
in public accommodations which meant
that public accountant debuted public
accommodations as something purely
private rather than a civil right a
quasi-governmental right or a quasi
public right and that's one of the big
distinctions between the majority and
the dissent in both the civil rights
cases and in Plessy versus Ferguson the
court ruled that in fact that so long as
the state of Louisiana maintained
separate but equal facilities they could
do that that that was not prohibited by
the Fourteenth Amendment the Supreme
Court in 1896 rules seven to one that
the separate car act is constitutional
so a state is allowed to segregate its
public conveyances including rail cars
by race the Court denies that the
separate car act violates the Fourteenth
Amendment to the Constitution what the
court basically says is look the law
says the railway cars have to be equal
even if they're separate and all the
Fourteenth Amendment requires is that
basic equality in civil rights John
Marshall Harlan of course dissented from
that I think that it's important to
understand what was the actual nature of
Harlan's dissent rather than the way
that is actually portrayed Harlan is is
famous talking about it the colorblind
Constitution but he's also but in fact
what he says is with respect to civil
rights common rights common to all
citizens I don't have the the exact
language before me that the that the
Constitution was required to be
colorblind so one of the big
distinctions between the majority and
the dissent is that Harlan does in fact
believe that the right to use public
transportation counted as a civil right
which was and therefore was protected
against segregation by section 1 of the
14th amendment so that because I want to
make that point because it's pretty
clear that Harlan believed for example
that maintenance of segregated schools
would be constitutional and it's also
true that Harlan voted for to say that
miscegenation laws mcgraw were
constitutional the dissenting judge
justice Harlan himself a former
supporter of slavery who changed his
views and eventually became known as a
champion of black civil rights right so
justice Harlan the lone dissenter one of
the only southern judges on the court
but the others were basically northern
both Republican and Democrat they didn't
have strong views about race I unusually
they should didn't have unusually strong
views about race for their time and they
maintained this distinction between
social and civil rights
it's important to understand in trying
to understand the context of Plessy vs.
Ferguson that the Supreme Court used to
distinguish between what it called civil
rights and what it called social rights
civil rights were basically rights to
participate in civil society and
included rights like the right to enter
into contracts the right to buy property
the right to testify in court the court
understood social rights as something
very different from that which is really
the right to do all of those things in
the company of people of a different
race
that's fascinating so what was the
effect of this ruling in Plessy versus
Ferguson there are two ways that you
could look at it that until 1954 the
effect of the ruling was to allow that
was to say that these state governments
were allowed to segregate their
citizenry on the basis of a race that's
one way you could look at it now one of
the interesting questions is how much
difference it would have made given the
sort of culture of the southern states
even if the court held that it was
unconstitutional for the state to
formally require segregation among the
races that is that there was a lot of
there are a lot of informal pressures
which would which would have pushed
towards segregation even if the even if
the court had said that it was uncut the
statute was unconstitutional but we'll
never know that so in other words the
question in Plessy is not whether the
federal government was going to mandate
segregation but rather whether the
federal government was simply going to
Louise just leave the states and their
citizenry to their own devices in
determining whether to segregate their
public transportation and some other
things so this concept of separate but
equal is I think the most important
thing that comes out of Plessy versus
Ferguson and then later you know will we
issue in the 20th century so it was
separate ever equal in theory or in
practice it was very clear at the time
and justice Harlan says so in his
dissenting opinion in Plessy that the
practice of separating railway cars or
any another number on any number of
other public accommodations by race was
not designed for the comfort of black
Americans it was designed in order to
maintain their social inferiority
through legal institutions so once you
no longer have the institution of
slavery there was a felt need among many
in the south to maintain the system of
social relations that slavery
represented and that's what Jim Crow was
all about and everyone knew that's what
Jim Crow was all about so Jim Jim Crow
was really kind of in its infancy when
Plessy vs. Ferguson was decided laws
that prevented blacks from voting
through a number of their literacy
requirements and property requirements
and and good character requirements and
so forth those kinds of laws were very
much in their infancy at the time Plessy
versus Ferguson was decided and so the
whole system of segregation is really
revving up in the 1890s and the court
just gives it carte blanche to continue
after that and it's important to
remember that as of the 1890s the
Supreme Court had not admitted to ever
have in reversed one of its own
decisions the lawyers who brought the
Plessy case we're quite clear about this
the assumption was that once the court
ruled it was going to be an awfully long
time before you could get the court to
reverse itself and that's in fact what
happened so the court does not reverse
Plessy versus Ferguson until Brown
versus Board of Education in 1954 and so
you had an almost 60 year period in
which practices of institutionalized
segregation had the blessing of the
Supreme Court so we've learned that in
Plessy
versus Ferguson the Supreme Court took a
narrow view of the Equal Protection
Clause ruling that separate but equal
accommodations for white and black
Americans did not violate the 14th
amendment Earl Maltz suggests that it's
difficult to tell if a different outcome
and Plessy vs. Ferguson would have made
much difference in the actions of
southern states if there was no
political will to enforce integration
anyway
Jamal Green by contrast reminds us that
segregation was just getting started at
the time of the Plessy case and this
ruling by the court legitimized Jim Crow
laws that would continue to spread for
nearly 60 years to learn more about
Plessy versus Ferguson check out the
National Constitution Center's
interactive Constitution and Khan
Academy's resources on US government and
history